with dlc dynamic themes and PS plus
discounts available there were plenty of
reasons to use PSN in February but what
were the top-selling games for that
month sony has revealed the best sellers
for the ps4 ps3 and PS Vita the number
one spots might surprise you counting
down on ps4 the top games where black
ops 3 grand theft auto 5 minecraft
madden 16 need for speed street fighter
5 naruto shippuden ultimate ninja storm
4 rocket League Far Cry primal and fire
watch props to developer Campo Santo for
taking the top spot fire watch did
release a few weeks ahead of
second-place winner Far Cry primal but
it's an accomplishment nonetheless as
for the ps3 need for speed most wanted
was the most downloaded game and for PS
Vita it was Digimon story cyber sleuth
and he make surprises there remember
those rankings are for number of
downloads not total revenue sony also
released top 10 lists for playstation
classics and add-ons we've got all that
info at gamespot and if you're trying to
keep up with all the latest in
playstation news you're already in the
right place
you